>> A BIG LIBERAL CITY SIDING
WITH HOLLYWOOD.
CHICAGO POLICE REPORTEDLY
DIVERTING SOME OFFICERS AWAY
FROM PATROLLING THE NEIGHBORHOOD
SO THEY CAN PROTECT TV AND
MOVIES HAD TO INSTEAD.
IN RESPONSE TO AN INCIDENT THAT
HAPPEN ON A FILM SITE WHERE A
SUSPECT LIT AND THREW AN
IDENTIFIED OBJECT.
NO ONE WAS HURT BUT THE
WINDY CITY IS ALREADY STRUGGLING
WITH POLICE STAFFING SHORTAGES
AS RAMPANT CRIME CONTINUES.
CHICAGO PD SAYING WE WORK
CLOSELY WITH THE CITY'S FILM AND
TELEVISION, NEED TO PROVIDE
SAFETY AND SECURITY FOR THE
PRODUCTION AND THE COMMUNITIES
IN WHICH THEY FOUND.
GEORGE, I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS IS THERE'S JUST NOT
ENOUGH POLICE.
NOT ENOUGH LAW ENFORCEMENT SO
THEY ARE DIVERTING.
HE WOULD THINK THAT THE MOVIE
STUDIOS COULD HIRE PRIVATE
SECURITY.
>> Judge Jeanine: THAT'S
EXACTLY THE POINT.
I LIVED IN CHICAGO FOR SEVERAL
YEARS.
I WOULD GO BACK AND FORTH.
I LOVE CHICAGO.
IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
THE SAD PART IS WHEN THEY MAKE A
DECISION THAT THEY WANT TO
DIVERT RESOURCES FOR PEOPLE
COMING IN TO MAKE TV SHOWS AND
MOVIES, YOU SAY TO YOURSELF, THE
POOR PEOPLE ON THE SOUTH SIDE OR
THOSE THAT ARE NOW IN THE LOOP
AREA APPARENTLY, ALREADY HAVING
DANGEROUSLY LOW STAFFING
PROBLEMS AS IT RELATES TO THE
POLICE.
THE TV AND MOVIE PEOPLE OUGHT TO
HIRE THEIR OWN SECURITY.
YOU THINK ABOUT IT, THE POLICE
AND THE BUSINESSES PAY TAXES FOR
POLICE TO DEFEND THEM AND
PROTECT THEM.
IF YOU COME IN FROM OUT-OF-STATE
OR YOU COME INTO DO A MOVIE,
MAYBE YOU SHOULD HAVE YOUR OWN
SECURITY.
THE SADDEST PART IS 47 PEOPLE
WERE SHOT IN CHICAGO THIS PAST
WEEKEND.
NOT ONE PERSON WAS ARRESTED.
47 SHOT.
EIGHT KILLED.
EIGHT DAD.
NOT ONE ARREST.
>> WITH THE JUDGE IS SAYING.
THEY ARE TRYING TO HIRE THEIR
OWN, THEY ARE TRYING.
THEY HAVE TO HIRE OFF-DUTY COPS.
>> Judge Jeanine: NO, THEY
DON'T.
>> THERE IS NOBODY TO HIRE AND
NOBODY WANTS TO COME DO IT.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
I LIVE IN A TOWN IN GEORGIA WHEN
A LOT OF FILMING IS BEING DONE.
MAYBE IF YOU CAN KEEP YOUR
PEOPLE SEE IF YOU DON'T GET TO
PROFIT OFF MOVIE INDUSTRY.
THE SIMPLEST PART OF THE SOCIAL
CONTRACT, SECURITY.
IF YOU CAN'T GIVE PEOPLE A
SEMBLANCE OF THAT, REBUKE DON'T
GET TO INVOLVE YOURSELF IN THE
MOVIE INDUSTRY.
MAYBE YOU HAVE OTHER THINGS YOU
SHOULD FOCUS ON.
MAY BE AN INDUSTRY OF
ENTERTAINMENT AND FUN AND
CELEBRITIES ISN'T WITH THE MAYOR
NEEDS TO BE CATERING TO BUT
BECAUSE THE PEOPLE ARE IN A DIRE
SITUATION.
THAT'S AN IDEA.
IF YOU WANT TO COME TO GEORGIA,
YOU WON'T GET SHOT AT BUT YOU
MIGHT HAVE TO EAT FRIED CHICKEN
AND CORN BREAD.
WE HAVE A LOT OF MOVIES MADE
THERE.
>> Dana: THE MOVIE INDUSTRY,
THEY GET TAX BREAKS ANYWAY AS
INCENTIVES IN ORDER TO GET
THERE.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT THE PROBLEMS
IN CHICAGO AND THEY GO FAR
BEYOND HOLLYWOOD.
THE MAYOR WHO CAN'T RUN THE CITY
AND THEN YOU SEE IT SHOW UP IN
SO MANY DIFFERENT WAYS.
NOT ONLY THAT WHEN SHE RAN SHE
PROMISED SHE WAS GOING TO
SUPPORT PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
SHE HAS CONTENTION WITH
TEACHERS.
WHAT YOU HAVE SEEN IS ON THE
SOUTH AND WEST SIDE OF CHICAGO
WHERE YOU HAVE MIDDLE-CLASS
FAMILIES, UPPER-CLASS FAMILIES
WHO HAVE HOUSES.
C.J. WALKER'S ORIGINAL HOUSES
THERE, THE FIRST BLACK
MILLIONAIRE.
THEY HAVE A MISTRUST FOR THE
POLICE AND A LACK OF CONFIDENCE
IN THE MAYOR AND THE CITY OF
CHICAGO.
I WOULD PREDICT THAT NEXT YEAR
AND HER PRIMARY YOU WILL
PROBABLY SEE MARY LORI LIGHTFOOT
UNSEATED.
SHE RAN WITH A LOT OF PROMISES
SHE HASN'T FILLED ANY OF THEM.
>> Dana: SHE HAS ANNOUNCED
THAT SHE WANTS TO RUN FOR OFFICE
AGAIN.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF HOLLYWOOD?
>> Greg: THEY SHOULD STOP
CALLING IT THE WINDY CITY.
THEY SHOULD CALL THE PEOPLE SHOT
IN THE FACE CITY.
MORE PEOPLE SHOT IN THE FACE
THEN HIT BY THE WIND.
>> Judge Jeanine: IT'S WINDY.
I WAS KNOCKED DOWN BY THE WIND
ONCE ON MICHIGAN AVENUE.
>> Greg: THERE IS A GOOD
REASON WHY THE POLICE ARE ON A
MOVIE SET BECAUSE PEOPLE DIE ON
THEM.
JUST ASK ALEC BALDWIN.
IT'S TOTALLY NORMAL TO HAVE
THESE PEOPLE HERE BUT IT IS A
REMINDER THAT THE FILM INDUSTRY,
HOLLYWOOD AND TV, THEY WILL
HAPPILY DENIGRATE
LAW ENFORCEMENT UNTIL THEY NEED
THEM.
WE NEED A GUY WITH A GUN ON SET
BECAUSE OUR ARE STARING AT US.
SURE, I'LL TAKE PICTURES FROM
THE -- WITH THE COPS.
THEY WILL GO ON TWITTER AND CRAP
ALL OVER THE POLICE.
I HAVE NO BEEF IF YOU APPLY THE
SAME CONCERNS AND PRODUCTIONS
FOR THE COMMUNITY.
WHAT YOU DO FOR THE FILMMAKERS,
YOU DO FOR THE CITIZENS.
IF YOU ARE PROTECTING THE CAST
OF LINE ORATION PROVIDING LAW IN
ORDER TO EVERYONE ELSE.
IF YOU ARE PULLING PEOPLE OUT OF
UNSAFE AREAS TO DO IT, IT IS